chaque année les premiers concerts du
Sakifo se font ici au foyer Albert
Barbot de Saint-Pierre une tradition qui
tient à cœur ses adultes concernés par
une déficience intellectuelle ou en
situation de handicap psychique ce matin
le groupe Joe Dary est à l'honneur
maintenant
[Musique]
300 résidents mélangés à 400 jeunes de
bois d'olives un partenariat une
tradition entre la fondation du père
Favre roux
on a à cœur de d'emmener la culture et
la musique aux personnes qui en fait qui
n'ont pas forcément accès à cette
culture comme eux ils peuvent pas venir
ben nous on y va et du coup en fait on
le fait avec plaisir et voyez Albert
Barbeau il y a cette volonté de montrer
aux gens ce mieux vivre ensemble ça leur
permet de sortir en fait de leur service
déjà de leur lieu de vie et de pouvoir
en fait profiter d'un concert musical
d'un événement culturel
et de le partager surtout avec des
enfants des personnes de l'extérieur
c'est comme une ouverture pour eux mais
sur le site
[Musique]
quelque chose de beau
rassemblez grâce à la musique un public
diversifié et intergénérationnel
sensibilisés sur la différence sur le
vivre ensemble peut-être que Fanny et
Ludivine ne se pose pas des questions
sur les enjeux de cette action
culturelle non elle s'en moque car elle
vivent pleinement l'instant présent
et puis votre chanteur
[Musique]
Joy dari Alexandre Saya et au milieu les
tambours de bois d'olive une fin en
beauté abois d'olive ce matin des
sourires des déhanchements un moment
suspendu pour tous ces résidents